eine absolute weltpremiere kampf der
quantencomputer
das finde ich wirklich den absoluten
wahnsinn erstmals haben forscher zwei
unterschiedliche quantenrechner
gegeneinander antreten lassen und welche
verfahren was ihr unterschied und wieder
schnell ausgegangen ist dass der vater
jetzt hier bei klicks und ein sandwich
kontur ich bin ja gerade unterwegs also
herzlich willkommen das ist eigentlich
egal was in diesem video sieht mit einem
smartphone laptop oder martini das sind
alles digital computer also maschinen
deren arbeitsweise auf den prinzipien
der physik und informatik basieren wie
wild digital bestehen aus schaltern und
schaltkreisen mit ein und aus also 1 und
0 funktionieren acht deutscher bis 0
oder 1 bilden einen weiteren können zum
beispiel buchstaben definieren 1 a bis
zum beispiel 0 1 000 001 werden
entwickelt die wissenschaftler
quantencomputer die uhr als vielfaches
leistungsfähiger sind als bisher da
gewesene das sind dann keine schalter
mehr die an oder ausgemacht werden
sondern wir rechnen mit dem zustand von
veilchen der sich je nach dem ändert und
sie können parallel riesige datenmengen
verarbeiten
das ganze funktioniert mit der
überlagerung von zuständen der super
position wie bei wellen im wasser können
sich zustände von teilchen überlagern
ohne sich zu stören es kann also
deutlich mehr zustande als null und eins
geben und es funktioniert mit der
sogenannten quantenverschränkung wenn
teilchen miteinander verschränkt sind
könne informationen an beiden teilchen
abgelesen werden was mit dem ein
teilchen passiert ist zur gleichen zeit
an den anderen reizen ablesbar
es wird also zur datenübertragung keine
also wirklich keine zeit mehr benötigt
jüngstem einstein
gerade wurde zum ersten mal ein foto
nasa nicht veilchen mit einer million
rubidium atome verschränkt der findet
fotos also der drehmomente photon konnte
so auf eine million rubidium atome
übertragen werden und an ihnen jederzeit
abgelesen werden denn das ist ein
bisschen der haken der quantencomputer
informationen wird beim auslesen
zerstört also wenn ich das teilchen
beobachte endet sich der zustand in
diesem fall
kann die informationen also eine million
mal ausgelesen werden
das war die erfindung des quanten
speichert die forschung im bereich
quantencomputer schiebt noch relativ
weit am anfang es gibt verschiedene
verfahren so einen computer aufzubauen
war diese rechner bisher nur wer
bestimmte und unterschiedliche aufgaben
erfüllen können war bisher nur sehr
schwer diese verschiedenen ansätze
miteinander zu vergleichen
forscher der university of maryland war
selbst schafft einen quantencomputer
frei zu programmieren die wir rechnen
aber nur fünf die therapie union als
kubitz also quantenbits und diese
stecken in magnet fallen und werden von
einem leser programmiert der sie
paarweise verschreckt informationen
werden hier durch ihr energieniveau
verarbeitet dieser rechner konnten also
mit einem anderer bauart vergeben werden
und hier wird von ibm produziert die
kugel existieren hier virtuell in
bereichen von supraleitern und werden
franz markowitz genannt mit hilfe von
mikrowellen lassen sich diese
supraleiter in den vorgang mehr fanden
computer besteht aus fünf solcher
metallspuren gespeichert werden die
informationen hier in der spannung der
supraleiter inter nun haben die forscher
die beiden systemen vier algorithmen
berechnen lassen und um einen vergleich
fühlen zu können haben sie sich folgende
aspekte angeschaut korrektheit der
ergebnisse zuverlässigkeit und dauer der
rechenoperation und tatsächlich fanden
sie teilweise sehr markante unterschiede
der ibm rechner war teilweise bis zu
1000 mal schneller als sein konkurrent
dieser hatte jedoch eine deutlich höhere
zuverlässigkeit der ionen rechner kam
auf einen wert von 77 bis 90 prozent
während der ibm rechner nur auf 35 74
prozent kam
beim sogenannten bernstein war pirani
algorithmus schaffte der ionen rechner
doppelt so oft korrekte ergebnisse zu
liefern wie der ibm rechner
die gründe für die unterschiede sehen
die forscher in den verschiedenen
bauarten der maschinen die kugel
pressionen rechner seien viel stärker
miteinander verknüpft jedes jungen kann
bei jedem anderen interagieren
bei dem ibm rechner läuft das über einen
cent
spuhler mit den ergebnissen konnten die
forscher feststellen auf welche faktoren
es in zukunft ankommt die st das sind
wichtige erkenntnisse wenn es um das
künftige hochskalieren von
quantencomputern geht zurück monroe von
der university of merit
wer sich nach dem video jetzt denke was
für ein komplexes thema dem kann ich
dafür buch die quanten sind eine
hoffnungslose schweinerei empfehlen über
unseren hörbuch link hier bei
unternehmen und natürlich in der video
beschreibung bekommt er dafür buch sogar
zum kostenlosen probeabo
dazu geschenkt also hört mal rein und
jetzt drückt mir da noch ein abo aufs
auge und liegt mir einen auf die glocke
um kein video mehr zu verpassen
ansonsten bislang bleibt